I cannot believe that the majority of
Americans want to finance the detention
of innocent people hi i'm anthony fisher
with recent TV and I'm joined by Hena
Shamsi the director of the National
Security Project with the American Civil
Liberties Union and one of the lawyers
representing Mamadou ruled slaw he the
author of the Guantanamo diary and a
current inmate at Guantanamo Bay thanks
so much for joining us it's a pleasure
to be with you can you tell us a little
bit about slaw he and what his
background was and how he ended up in US
custody absolutely
so Muhammadu is a 44 year old more
Italian citizen he was born there he won
a scholarship to Germany and went and
studied engineering in Germany he'd
returned to Mauritania in around 2000
and voluntarily turned himself in to
questioning by the Mauritania and police
and that would be the last his family
saw of him over the next 14 years he was
transferred to Jordan where he was
tortured and abused transferred again by
the United States to Bagram where he was
further tortured and abused and then
transferred to Guantanamo in August 2002
where he was subjected to a special
interrogation program that terrible
euphemism we've come to now know is
torture
authorized specifically by Donald
Rumsfeld he remains there still why was
the United States looking for him after
9/11 the United States
remember at this period of time the
United States was picking up people in
around the world and capturing them
sending some to black sites sending
others to Guantanamo and they picked him
up based on a variety of suspicions
which have all been shown to be false so
they alleged involvement in the
Millennium plot turned out not to be
true alleged millennium plan which was
to attack the Los Angeles Airport that's
right
that's turned out not to be true they
alleged that he was a recruiter for
al-qaeda
that's turned out not to be true and I
think it's important to point out that
the only neutral person who has
evaluated all the facts
case is a federal judge who in 2010
ordered Mohammad who released but the
government appealed and he still remains
at Guantanamo but he did swear
allegiance to al-qaeda in early 90s and
went to Afghanistan to fight the Soviets
correct correct and he admits that he's
admitted that to the military over and
over again and what he said and what the
judge found was that he went like so
many others to Afghanistan to fight the
communist regime there in the early 90s
he was part of a movement that was at
the time supported by the United States
and the al Qaeda that he joined was very
different and the judge said this from
what al Qaeda later became he had no
connection with them post 1992 no there
was no evidence of any threats of
violence or religious extremism that
would have tied him to what we know of
his bin Laden's al Qaeda no and he's
repeatedly rejected that he describes
that also in his book so there is
actually no evidence of a legal basis to
detain him he's never been part of the
armed conflict between the United States
and al Qaeda and he's never participated
in any hostilities against the United
States let's talk a little bit about the
book he wrote the book in 2005 and now
it's 2015 and it's being released to
wide acclaim can you talk a little bit
about how he came to write the book and
how it was able to get out and see the
light of day well I'll start with an
anecdote which I think gives you a
flavor of who Muhammadu is which is that
when of one of our co-counsel asked him
to talk about the interrogations that he
had gone through to describe all of the
interrogations his response was are you
crazy
that's like asking Charlie Sheen how
many women he stated but in around the
summer and fall of 2005 he started
writing down because he wanted the world
to know and he specifically wanted
Americans to know his story this is a
book that's very much addressed to all
of us it turned into a 400 plus page
manuscript and we his lawyers fought for
over six years through litigation and
negotiation with the government to get
it cleared for release it was cleared
with over 2,500 redactions those
reductions are still in the book as
published but it is I think and I hope
people will read it and find a deeply
humane human and sometimes even funny
account of one man's journey through the
the arduous place that the United States
took him and I think another part of
this that's so unusual is that Muhammad
whose account is of being in a place
that was established to demian humanize
people like him and he sets out in his
book to describe what that's like but he
also humanizes those who are supposed to
represent us his American jailers some
of them his tortures and interrogators
and you get a real sense of what it is
that we have done not only to the
victims of our policies but what it is
that we do to our military service
members when we ask them tera Gators to
break the minds and bodies of human
beings can you talk a little bit about
that how what's an example in the book
of him trying to humanize his captors he
tells he tries to understand why his
interrogators are are asking him these
questions he talks about his guards with
some of the guards he the friendlier
guards he engages in discussions about
politics about religion about chess some
of those guards become his friends they
give him books when they are leaving off
rotation hoping that he's going to
someday be released and I think that
that humanity comes through he talks
about how this wasn't a family that he
chose but because of the circumstances
he's in some of these people are the
family that he now has even as he yearns
for the family that he has not seen for
over 14 years for a time the US
government was claiming that slaw he
would bro
and was one of their greatest sources of
information on al-qaeda and now it
doesn't appear that much of the
information he gave is useful at all can
you talk a little bit about why the u.s.
is positioned on the information he gave
has changed well I can tell you what
Muhammadu says in the book about the
information that he was providing to the
government which is that he was
subjected to terrible torture beatings
stress positions extreme temperatures
faked execution threats against his
mother's and after a period of that he
started to self-incriminating
he said I told them you know the worst
about myself because that's what they
wanted to hear and so you get a real
sense about the only two things that
torture guarantees which is false
information and pain
there's one part of the book that that
is particularly striking in that way he
says that
he learned to forget the words I don't
know because when he thought about those
words he grew nauseous what stops llahi
from petitioning for habeas for habeas
corpus well Mamadou did petition for
habeas corpus and that's where we
represented him in court and that's
where you know he's still waiting for
his case to go forward one key aspect of
this is he like so many of the other men
at Montana mo is being held without
charge or trial and there are two
military prosecutors former military
prosecutors who refused to go forward on
his case one of them Colonel Stuart
couch found out about the torture and
decided that as a man of religion ethics
and morals he could no longer continue
on Mohammed his case the second is the
former chief military prosecutor at
Guantanamo Colonel Morris Davis who said
that he tried to look for any crime with
which to charge Mohammed doing the
military commissions and couldn't find
one can you talk a little bit about
slacking now he's aware that the book
has been published and that it's gotten
a positive reception
what's weird what is his life like now
and what's next for him well because of
the government secrecy regime at
Guantanamo I can't describe to you what
life is like for him what I can tell you
is that he's in a prison he's in a
terrible place he was recently visited
by one of our my co-counsel who told him
that his book had become a New York
Times bestseller and was on the
bestseller list for three weeks about
the close to 50,000 people who signed a
petition that by the ACLU for his
release and he was deeply deeply moved
he is tired he's been through a lot he's
never been charged with a crime he wants
to go home this book is really addressed
to the American public and at the end of
the book Mohammed who says I want to
know what the public thinks I cannot
believe that the majority of Americans
want to finance the detention of
innocent people and this book is his
hope that people of conscience people
who are committed to Liberty's will read
it be moved by it and be moved to do
something about it
what do you what do you say to people
who think that indefinite detention
without charges is in the national
security interests definite detention
without charge or trial is deeply
American American goes against our laws
and our values but let's take on that
argument which is that there are a tiny
tiny fraction of people released from
Guantanamo all of them released by the
Bush administration who have been
accused of being hostile to or engaging
in acts against Americans Guantanamo is
very existence right is according to the
president national security experts
military and intelligence a national
security threat to us the fact that it
exists hurts our national security it
also hurts our finances and economies
the current estimated cost by Miami
Herald of holding a single prisoner at
Guantanamo for a year is over three
million dollars now
so when it hurts our laws our values our
morality our ethics there is no good
argument to keep it in place and it
should be closed we've been talking with
henna Shamsi the director of the
National Security Project with the
American Civil Liberties Union and one
of the lawyers representing Mamadou
ruled Salahi the author of the
Guantanamo diary thanks so much for
joining us for recent TV I'm Anthony
Fisher